Traductor: Denise RQ
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
La depresión es la causa principal
de discapacidad en el mundo.
En Estados Unidos
casi el 10 % de los adultos
sufren de depresión.
Sin embargo, al tratarse
de una enfermedad mental,
es más difícil de entender que
el colesterol alto, por ejemplo.
Una causa importante de confusión
es la diferencia entre padecerla
y simplemente sentirse deprimido.
Casi todo el mundo se siente
desanimado de vez en cuando.
Cuando recibimos una mala calificación,
al perder el empleo, al tener una pelea,
incluso un día de lluvia puede
inspirar sentimientos de tristeza.
A veces no hay ni siquiera una razón.
Aparece de la nada.
Luego las circunstancias cambian
y los sentimientos de
tristeza desaparecen.
La depresión clínica es diferente.
Es un problema médico,
y no desaparecerá solo porque quieres.
Tiene una duración
de al menos dos semanas
y afecta la capacidad de trabajo, a
la hora de divertirse o la vida amorosa.
La depresión puede presentar
diversos síntomas: apatía,
pérdida de interés por las cosas
que generalmente te gustan,
cambios en el apetito,
sentirse inútil
o excesivamente culpable,
dormir demasiado o muy poco,
dificultad para concentrarse,
estar demasiado agitado o lento,
tener falta de energía o pensamientos
suicidas recurrentes.
Si tienes por lo menos
5 de estos síntomas
según las directrices psiquiátricas,
encajas en el diagnóstico
de la depresión.
Y los síntomas no son
simplemente de conducta.
La depresión se manifiesta
físicamente en el cerebro.
En primer lugar, se producen cambios
que pueden observarse a simple vista
y por medio de visión de rayos X,
en la zona inferior de los lóbulos
frontales y en el hipocampo.
A escala microscópica la depresión
se asocia con ciertas cosas:
la transmisión anormal o reducción
de ciertos neurotransmisores,
especialmente serotonina,
norepinefrina y dopamina,
ritmos circadianos alterados,
o cambios característicos en las fases
REM o alfa de los ciclos de sueño,
y disfunciones hormonales,
como aumento en los niveles de cortisol
y desregulación de
las hormonas tiroideas.
Pero sin embargo, los neurocientíficos
no tienen una imagen completa
de lo que causa la depresión.
Parece que tiene que ver
con la interacción compleja
entre la genética y el medio ambiente,
pero no es una herramienta de diagnóstico
capaz de predecir con precisión
dónde y cuándo se va a producir.
Como los síntomas de la
depresión son intangibles,
es difícil saber quién la padece,
aunque parezca saludable.
Según el Instituto Nacional
de la Salud Mental en EE.UU.,
una persona común
con una enfermedad mental
demora más de 10 años en pedir ayuda.
Pero existen tratamientos muy eficaces.
Medicación y terapia se complementan
para estimular la química del cerebro.
En casos extremos,
la terapia de electroshock,
que es una convulsión controlada
inducida en el cerebro del paciente,
también ayuda mucho.
Otros tratamientos prometedores, como
la estimulación magnética transcraneal
también ayudan mucho.
Así que si conoces a alguien
que sufre de depresión,
alienta a esta persona, amablemente
a que considere algunas de esas opciones.
Puede que te ofrezcas para ayudar
en tareas concretas
como buscar terapeutas en la zona,
o hacer una lista de preguntas
para consultarle al médico.
Para alguien con depresión,
estos primeros pasos
pueden parecer insuperables.
Si esa persona se siente
culpable o avergonzada,
explícale que la depresión
es un problema médico,
como el asma o la diabetes.
No es una debilidad
o un rasgo de la personalidad,
y que no debe creer que puede
superarla y recuperarse,
así como no se queda de brazos cruzados
en el caso de un brazo roto.
Si tú mismo no has sufrido de depresión,
evita comparar la enfermedad con
momentos en que estabas desanimado.
Comparar la experiencia
de estas personas
con los sentimientos normales
pero fugaces de tristeza normal
puede hacerles que se sientan
culpables por su sufrimiento.
Incluso hablar abiertamente
sobre la depresión puede ayudar.
Por ejemplo, la investigación muestra
que hablar de pensamientos suicidas
en realidad reduce el riesgo de suicidio.
Las conversaciones francas
sobre las enfermedades mentales
ayudan a acabar con el estigma
y hacer más fácil pedir ayuda.
Y cuanto más pacientes busquen ayuda,
más científicos avanzarán
en la investigación de la depresión
y los tratamientos serán más eficaces.